[Música]
una revolución social contra la pobreza
alrededor de 430.000 kilos de basura se
generan diariamente en latinoamérica lo
que para nosotros es basura para 4
millones de familias latinoamericanas es
un medio de vida una forma de vida
altamente peligroso por las condiciones
de insalubridad e inseguridad a las
cuales están expuestas una forma de vida
que no les permite romper ese círculo
vicioso de inequidad y pobreza
soy antonella romero abogada de
profesión y emprendedora por decisión
cofundadora de trier una startup social
peruana que busca transformar la vida de
miles de mujeres latinoamericanas que se
dedican al oficio de reciclaje
para contarles un poco más en mi país
hoy 108 mil familias sobreviven con el
reciclaje así como lo escucha sobrevive
el 40 por ciento de esas familias tienen
como cabeza a una mujer una mujer que
percibe ingresos diarios menores a 7
dólares y que trabaja durante más de 15
horas en jornadas extenuantes cargando
sobre sus hombros 40 kilos diarios de
productos reciclados esta situación se
da porque ellas no tuvieron la
oportunidad de hacer una educación de
calidad el 60 por ciento de escolares
que egresan hoy en día de las aulas de
los colegios públicos no pueden acceder
una educación superior técnica
universitaria que les permite hacer
dueño de su futuro el 40 por ciento son
mujeres y mujeres que hoy en día se
dedican a reciclaje al no tener
oportunidades encontraron en este oficio
un escape
es así que mi socio y yo nos preguntamos
cómo es posible que en pleno siglo 21 no
existe una solución para este problema
social es por ello que donde algunos ven
problema nosotros encontramos una
oportunidad de desarrollar un modelo de
negocio social inclusivo que busque
transformar la vida de esas mujeres y
las empodere como microempresarias
generando valor porque no basta con que
las empresas generen ingresos si es que
éstas no buscan trascender en la vida de
las personas es así que unimos nuestras
pasiones y con ayuda de la tecnología
desarrollamos un aplicativo móvil el
cual permite que cada uno de ustedes
usuarios potenciales puedan enviar una
notificación un reciclador lo recibe se
acerca a su domicilio les entrega el
producto segregado y a cambio de ello
ustedes reciben puntos que
posteriormente pueden ser canjeados como
premios o descuentos en centros
comerciales tiendas por departamento y
servicios diversos
con este modelo lo que buscamos es
concientizar a la ciudadanía acerca de
la importancia del reciclaje
ella es marta y esta es su revolución
creo firmemente que los jóvenes nuestra
generación están llamados a dar
soluciones reales a los problemas en la
sociedad somos nosotros los jóvenes los
líderes que ayudaremos a cambiarle la
vida de marta y de miles de mujeres
latinoamericanas las cuales también
podrán cambiar el futuro de sus hijos
que sean los futuros líderes en nuestros
países no sólo somos un modelo de
negocio rentable sino una solución
sostenible para el problema del
reciclaje es por eso que los invito a
ustedes a que sean parte de este sueño a
que involucremos a las empresas que cada
vez están apostando por proyectos de
responsabilidad social que nos
involucremos como sociedad civil para
dar una solución a este problema y los
invito a algo más importante a sumarse a
este sueño y a sumarse a esta revolución
[Aplausos]